el estruendo de las bombas rusas se
mezcla con el llanto de estos bebés sus
madres biológicas viven a miles de
kilómetros de la guerra en este sótano a
las afueras de kiev la capital ucraniana
21 recién nacido es fruto de gestación
subrogada sobreviven gracias a los
cuidados neonatales de las madres
sustitutas mujeres como shaka quien
desde hace 20 días no ve a su propia
familia
salimos rondó brazos abdomen no podemos
volver a casa desde el 24 de febrero soy
de la región de schumi pero no puedo ir
allí tengo niños en casa se quedan con
la abuela
y
nos quedamos aquí para cuidarlos quien
cuidará de ellos mientras sus padres no
estando hagan famosa
ucrania es uno de los principales países
del mundo donde la controvertida
subrogación es legal se calcula que cada
año nacen 2500 niños gestados por
mujeres ucranianas para parejas de
extranjeras a cambio de dinero pero el
conflicto ha empeorado las condiciones
de estas mujeres por lo general
procedentes de contextos empobrecidos
embarazadas y recién nacidos atrapados
por los ataques de las fuerzas rusas que
los últimos días se han ensañado contra
hospitales y objetivos civiles
estamos preocupados por nosotros por
nuestros propios hijos por estos bebitos
que se quedan aquí por todos es
aterrador porque nos sentamos aquí no
sabemos qué pasará aunque nos quedamos
en el sótano cuando hay una explosión en
algún lugar cercano podemos escucharla
muy claramente hubo algunas anoche es
aterrador
y el negocio de los vientres de alquiler
depende de una cuidadosa coordinación de
servicios legales y de viajes que ahora
están interrumpidos por la guerra las
embarazadas viven la disyuntiva de
quedarse en los refugios patrocinados
por las clínicas de subrogación o ir del
país con sus propias familias lo que
complicaría las cláusulas legales del
contrato con las familias extranjeras
una situación que agrava aún más salud
física y mental de estas ucranianas